Das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Je älter, umso stärker müssen die Spieler auch darauf vorbereitet werden, dass Fußball eine Ergebnissportart ist. Aber der Druck, gewinnen zu müssen, darf nie größer sein als der Spaß und die Freude. Die Egoversuchungen durch Ruhm und Reichtum, die sind schon extrem groß. Naja, aber du musst ja nicht zum Arschloch werden, nur weil du in dem Alter oder als Profi bekannt bist, Autogramme schreiben darfst. Ja, ich glaube, dass wir Trainer mehr denn je die Pflicht haben, nicht nur Technik, Taktik, Kondition, mentale Stärke und Teamfähigkeit zu vermitteln, sondern mehr denn je wichtige traditionelle Werte, wie zum Beispiel Respekt, Dankbarkeit, Demut.
Leroy Sané, Mesut Özil, Manuel Neuer, Benedikt Höwedes, Julian Draxler, Sejan Kolasinac und noch viele, viele mehr – sie alle sind durch die Hände von Norbert Elgert gegangen. U19-Trainer bei Schalke 04 und ziemlich sicher einer der bekanntesten Nachwuchstrainer Deutschlands. Und damit Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu diesem Tribünengespräch Nummer 35. Mein Name ist Max-Akob Ost. Ich bin der Gehnetzer bei Twitter und hatte die Freude, Norbert Elgert interviewen zu dürfen. Er hat ein Buch über sein Leben geschrieben. Es heißt, gib alles nuni auf. Erschien es im Arrest von Verlag und mithilfe des Journalisten Kai Psotter. Und wir haben genau dieses Buch zum Anlass genommen, ihn zu treffen und über sein Leben, seine Arbeit und seine Gedanken zum deutschen Nachwuchsfußball zu sprechen. Dieses Gespräch folgt gleich hier im Anschluss. Vorher bedanke ich mich aber noch bei Markus Schwemmer, Christine Turboris, Filo Florian und Max aus München benichtigt selbst. Wer sind diese Menschen, fragt ihr euch vielleicht. Das alles sind Rasenfunk-Supporterinnen und Supporter. Der Rasenfunk ist werbe- paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über die Freiwilligen. Unterstützungen unserer Supporterinnen und Supporter. Wer mehr dazu erfahren möchte, kann das tun auf rasenfunk.de slash unterstützen gibt es alle Informationen, wie man den Rasenfunk finanziell unterstützen kann und damit dieses Projekt hier am Leben erhalten. Und wer uns unterstützt, der kann sich dann auch registrieren im sogenannten Rasenfunk-Supporters-Club. Diesen Club verwenden wir vor allem dafür, um uns auch immer wieder bei euch zu bedanken, bei allen Unterstützerinnen und Unterstützern des Rasenfunks. Und in diesem hier vorliegenden Fall haben wir sogar eine Kleinigkeit, die wir euch zukommen lassen können. Der Ariston-Verlag hat uns freundlicherweise ein Exemplar des Buchs von Norbert Elgert zur Verfügung gestellt, das wir verlosen unter euch Supporterinnen und Supporter draußen. Wenn ihr Supporterinnen und Supporter seid und euch registriert habt, dann habt ihr in dieser Sekunde schon eine E-Mail bei euch im Postfach. In der ist alles beschrieben, wie ihr in dieser Verlosung teilnehmen könnt. Es läuft noch eine ganze Weile, bis zum Saisonbeginn habt ihr noch Zeit, an der Verlosung teilzunehmen. Alle Informationen bekommen die registrierten Supporterinnen und Supporter über diese E-Mail. Viel Glück euch allen! Jetzt würde ich sagen, gehen wir rein in das Gespräch. Ursprünglich war es mal geplant, in der Lobby eines Hotels in unmittelbarer Nähe an der Arena auf Schalke. Da waren dann aber die akustischen Bedingungen so, dass Norbert Elgert gesagt hat, ne, also das mach mal anders. Und dann saßen wir am Ende in seiner Trainerkabine, in der kleinen U19-Trainerkabine. Es ist ein bisschen so, wie man es sich vorstellt, spartanisch, alles auf Fußball reduziert, hat große Freude gemacht, auch genau an diesem Ort die Folge aufzunehmen. Und ich hoffe, das Gespräch, das dabei herausgekommen ist, bereitet euch auch Freude. Legen wir los. Viel Spaß mit dem Gespräch mit Norbert Elgert, U19-Trainer von Schalke 04. Herr Elgert, wir sind hier in der Trainerkabine auf Schalke. Ich durfte quasi ins Allerheiligste, herzlichen Dank dafür. Erzählen Sie mir doch mal ein bisschen, wo wir uns hier befinden, jetzt gar nicht so sehr vom Trainingsgelände hier, sondern von der Gegend. Wie ist das Ruhrgebiet? Wie sind die Leute hier drauf? Erzählen Sie mir ein bisschen von der Gegend.
Man bewegt sich sehr früh in einem Umfeld, in dem das Umfeld zu großen Teilen sagt, du bist der Allergrößte. Und dann kommt vielleicht ein U19-Trainer und sagt, nee, Moment, in dem Bereich bist du mir noch nicht gut genug und deswegen spielst du jetzt.
Nicht vielleicht. Der kommt dann ganz bestimmt.
Ist denn dann die Menschenkenntnis das, was einen guten von einem sehr guten Trainer unterscheidet? Ihrer Meinung nach?
Ja, das wäre vielleicht zu einfach, das darauf zu reduzieren. Also ein guter Trainer, ein guter Coach braucht sicherlich vieles Fachwissen. Es ist ähnlich wie bei einem Spieler, das Talent ist eine Bedingung, ist Grundvoraussetzung und das auch dann weiterzuentwickeln und immer auf neues Zustand zu bleiben, ist eine Grundvoraussetzung. Aber die wichtigsten, du musst die Dinge auch coachen und vermitteln können, also du musst Fußball lehren können, vermitteln können. Das sind Grundvoraussetzungen, die man aber auch verbessern kann. Allerwichtigste für mich ist, dass du Menschen magst. Dass du deine Spezies sogar liebst, jetzt bitte richtig verstehen. Dass das auch die Spieler spüren, dass du dich in Menschenreihen versetzen kannst, dass du Einfühlungsvermögen, Empathie hast, dass du emotionale Intelligenz hast. Das hat auch Otto Rehagel mal zu mir gesagt. Heute finde ich es schon wichtig, dass ein Fußballtrainer intelligent ist. Da spricht überhaupt nichts dagegen. Aber mir wird das heute oft überbetont.
Die Akademisierung unserer Welt findet man auch im Fußball so ein bisschen.
Ich glaube, der EQ ist wichtig. Aber über dem EQ, emotionale Intelligenz, halte ich für deutlich wichtiger. Denn was nützt dir ein Einstein-Intelligenzquotient, wenn du mit Menschen nicht umgehen kannst oder wenn du das Maul nicht aufkommst, wenn es drauf ankommt. Diese Dinge halte ich für deutlich wichtiger.
Und wie lange brauchen Sie im Gespräch mit einem neuen Spieler, um herauszufinden, wie derjenige tickt, wenn man das überhaupt so generalisieren kann?
Das ist unterschiedlich. Es ist auch unterschiedlich, ob introvertiert oder extrovertiert. Aber ich glaube, aufgrund meiner Erfahrung und dessen, dass ich mich dann auch schon ein paar Jahrzehnte mit Menschen befasse, dass ich das relativ gut und schnell erkennen kann, ist aber unterschiedlich. Es geht nicht nur über ein Gespräch. Du musst Menschen erst mal öffnen. Das gelingt manchmal im ersten Gespräch, manchmal erst nach dem zehnten, manchmal gar nicht. Erst dann kannst du ja auch Menschen beeinflussen, wie mit einem Gefäß. Wenn ein Gefäß verschlossen ist, da kann ich nichts reingießen. Du musst Menschen erst mal öffnen, man muss erst mal Vertrauen aufbauen. Ich erwarte nicht, nur weil ich einen ganz guten Namen habe im Fußball, dass sich jeder Spieler mir sofort öffnet, weil ich der und der Trainer bin. Das ist absolut individuell. Das kann ich aber ganz gut und auch relativ schnell einschätzen. Aber zeitlich kann ich ein Gespräch machen. Die Jungs sind ja alle anders. Jeder ist ja einmalig.
Das ist bei uns hier im Raum auch so. Wie hat sich denn die Haltung der Spieler verändert? Wenn ich mir jetzt angucke, zum Beispiel im Jahr 1999, Sie haben Ihren U19-Kader. Hat sich die Haltung der Spieler verändert, wie sie Ihnen als Trainerfigur begegnen?
Ich habe da, glaube ich, eine ziemlich starke, natürliche Autorität. Die habe ich, glaube ich, nicht trainiert. Meine Frau sagt immer, Gott sei Dank hast du das. Ich bin ja schon ein durchaus sensibler, feinfühliger Mensch, was nicht unbedingt ein Nachteil sein muss, wenn du Menschen führst. Ich bin da, glaube ich, sehr facettenreich, aber habe da mit der Autorität Gott sei Dank noch nie Probleme gehabt. Sonst ist es wie in einem – das ist eben so. Wenn du Menschen führst und es werden von dir Schwächen erkannt, das machen die gar nicht extra. Oder weil sie dich nicht leiden können, die Schwächen werden relativ schnell ausgenutzt, ob das Profis sind oder Jungprofis sind. Dann wirst du wie in einem Wolfshudel versuchen die Menschen dann relativ schnell deine Position unterbewusst einzunehmen. Sie wissen ja, dass sie da nicht Trainer werden können. Das war eigentlich schon immer so. Was sich verändert hat, ist sicherlich so dieser – es hat aber auch mit der Zeit, mit der Gesellschaft zu tun, der absolute Fokus auf Fußball. Zu meiner Zeit gab es nur Fußball, Fußball, Fußball. Heute bist du eben auch schneller auf diese – nach Malcolm Gladwell – diese zehn Jahre, 10.000 Stunden Fußball gekommen.
Ach, wenn man etwa 10.000 Stunden Fußball gemacht hat.
Ja, wobei das muss dann auch schon qualitativ hoch werden. Ja, genau. 10.000 Stunden rumpülen, da wirst du wahrscheinlich auch kein Profi. Aber dann bist du viel schneller auf diese Stunden gekommen. Weil heute für unsere Jungs ist das Vereinstraining der Fall. Und ansonsten sind die Freizeitmöglichkeiten, die Ablenkungsmöglichkeiten ja viel, viel größer. Über Digitalisierung, moderne Medien, Internet, Handy, Spielkonsolen. Viele, viele andere Dinge. Und von daher ist der Fokus heute – das kann man auch nicht verallgemeinern. Aber bei vielen eben nicht mehr so stark auf den Fußball, auf dieses große Ziel, also diesem Ziel wirklich alles unterzuordnen, und sonst wirst du das auch kaum schaffen können, ist häufig nicht mehr so stark.
Und das ist ja auch dann der Aspekt, der von vielen als eine Form der Bequemlichkeit kritisiert wird, wenn man es so formulieren möchte. Würden Sie das auch so sehen? Man kann das ja auch positiv deuten, dass heute junge Menschen nicht alles diesem einen Ziel unterordnen, bei dem ja die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man es erreicht, sehr, sehr gering ist, eben der Profifußball.
Ja, bin ich voll bei Ihnen. Von daher ist es auch immer wichtig, dass Arnold Schwarzenegger hat anders gedacht. Aber er war eben damals auch eine Ausnahmeerscheinung im Bodybuilding. Der hatte keine Alternative, hatte keinen Plan B. Dadurch kannst du natürlich auch nicht mehr zur Rock, es gibt nur den einen Weg. Aber da ist nur ein, zwei, drei, vier, fünf Prozent Schaffen. Bei allem Optimismus – und es ist wichtig, auch seinen Traum zu leben und an seinen Traum zu glauben – muss man trotzdem realistisch optimistisch dran gehen. Das bedeutet, dass du unbedingt einen Plan B brauchst. Das ist dann eben eine hochqualifizierte Schulausbildung, wenn eben möglich. Für viele hoffentlich dann auch Plan A, denn das werden die wenigsten schaffen. Für die meisten meiner Jungs ist Plan B schon für enorm wichtig, diesen Plan zu haben.
Und hören ihnen die Spieler auch zu, wenn sie ihnen sowas sagen? Ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin ja zu weit weg vom Fußballgeschäft, aber ich habe das Gefühl, dass gerade junge Fußballer im Juniorenbereich von sehr vielen Ecken sehr viele Meinungen hören, weil es da schon Berater gibt, zum Teil schon Sponsoren. Eltern waren schon immer ein Faktor. Und jetzt aber tatsächlich auch über soziale Medien kommen quasi anonyme Stimmen mit dazu. Ist es schwieriger geworden, da zu den Spielern durchzudringen?
Nein. Also es gelingt mir immer noch, vielleicht auch aufgrund meiner Vita, weil wir hier gemeinsam in der Knappenschmiede doch große Erfolge hatten in den letzten beiden Jahrzehnten. Ja und nichts ist dann überzeugender als eben solche Erfolge auch. Aber ich bin da ganz bei Ihnen, dass die Einflüsse heute natürlich viel, viel größer sind. Damals gab es nur die Familie, gab es einen Trainer. Und heute ist das Umfeld, was die Spieler betrifft. Es gibt den Berater. Gegen die bin ich nicht grundsätzlich. Es gibt Athletiktrainer. Auch die Berater haben dann ihre Zusatztrainer noch für die Spieler. Also die Einflüsse sind heute sicherlich schon gewaltig, sodass es insgesamt schwerer geworden ist, die Spieler zu überzeugen und zu erreichen. Bei uns, bei mir gelingt das aber immer noch, egal aus welchen Gründen, immer noch ganz gut. Ein großes Problem sehe ich in der Überbetonung des Talents. Dass du zu früh hochgejubelt wirst, dass zu früh schon in dir ein kommender Profi gesehen wird. Und dass dadurch häufig Dinge wie Einstellung – oder ich setze nochmal woanders an. Ich sage ja immer wieder, dass Talent dich in ein Fenster stellt, in eine Tür stellt. Aber dass erst Anstrengungsbereitschaft, Einstellung, Charakter, Durchhaltevermögen, Willenskraft dich durch diese Tür hindurchbringen, will heißen, dass du auch ein Talent dafür brauchst, dein Talent zu nutzen, dass du ein Talent dafür brauchst, Hindernisse und Widerstände zu überwinden. Und das ist vielleicht einer der Ansätze, wenn sie mich mal später irgendwas anders fragen, warum wir hier doch ziemlich erfolgreich waren. Weil ohne Anstrengungsbereitschaft, ohne all diese Dinge, kommt hier bei mir keiner durch, keiner in den Profikader. Weil das einfach nicht stabil genug ist. Und wenn du, also wen die Götter zerstören wollen, wen die Medien zerstören wollen, den machst du ganz früh öffentlich zum Supertalent.
Ja, denn dann wird es doppelt und dreifach schwer. Und das Schlimmste ist, wenn die Spieler dann selbst auch das vielleicht glauben. Sie haben geschrieben in ihrem Buch, zu einem erfolgreichen Geleben gehören für sie fünf Eckpfeiler. Erstens Gesundheit, zweitens Familie, drittens Beruf, viertens Glaube bzw. Spiritualität und fünftens Finanzen. Theoretisch wären sie ja eigentlich nur für einen dieser Punkte jetzt zuständig im Leben ihrer Spieler, nämlich für den Beruf. Wie viel aus den anderen Lebensbereichen versuchen sie denn da noch mitzugeben?
Ja, zum nächsten Mal ist es ja selbstverständlich. Und das ist auch sehr erfreulich, aber irgendwo für mich auch selbstverständlich, das für jeden meiner Jungs. Wir führen vor jeder Saison meist im Trainingslager oder wenn wir danach bei Turnieren unterwegs, da haben wir viel Zeit, ein etwas längeres Einzelgespräch, wo ich dann auch mehr über den Menschen, über die Persönlichkeit, seine Herkunft, wie denkt David Tickter, seine Ziele, Träume erfahren möchte. Und da kommt immer wieder raus, wenn ich frage, was ist für dich das Allerwichtigste in deinem Leben? Das Allerwichtigste. Und dann kommt fast immer Familie. Und das ist gut so. Das freut mich, weil ich das genauso sehe. Das ist dein Stamm, da kommst du her. Oder auch später, wenn du dann verheiratet bist, selbst eine Familie gründest. Das sind die Menschen, die immer zu dir halten, egal wie gut du spielst oder wie schlecht. Gesundheit, der Bauschneid. Das ist ja klar, dass sie das auch verstehen. Ich sage meinen Jungs nichts von Schopenhauer, der gesagt hat, die Gesundheit ist nicht alles. Aber ohne die Gesundheit ist alles nichts. Ihr Körper ist ihr Kapital. Wenn du verletzt bist, spielst du nicht. Wenn du krank bist, spielst du nicht. Wenn du zu lange verletzt bist, krank bist, bist du weg vom Fenster. Also es ist ja klar, dass die Gesundheit ein ganz wichtiger Baustein ist. Und da kann ich mit meiner Historie glaube ich echt ein Lied von singen. Dann, mit Spiritualität meine ich einfach Glaube. Und da geht es mir nicht darum, wer an was glaubt. Zu welcher Religion, aber ich finde es schon wichtig. Für mich ist es wichtig, an eine höhere Instanz zu glauben. Da versuche ich meine Jungs aber nicht zu überzeugen. Wenn sie mich fragen, wenn sie sich mit mir darüber unterhalten wollen, dann ist das wichtig. Dann spreche ich darüber. Und Finanzen habe ich ja auch selber erfahren. Was, wenn du verschuldet bist, das ist nicht schön. Aber irgendwo hängen die Dinge alle miteinander. Du kannst genauso wenig wie du Taktik, Technik, Athletik, mentales Team zu sehr segmentieren solltest. Das macht man ja heute auch nicht mehr unbedingt. Wird aber immer noch ein bisschen getan. Kannst du diese Dinge, die gehören alle irgendwo zusammen für mich? Diese Säulen haben sich in meinem Leben, da habe ich zwar auch andere Menschen beeinflusst, aber die haben sich irgendwann bei mir so herauskristallisiert.
Also wir haben schon gelernt, sie lesen unheimlich viel. Ihr Buch ist auch voll von Motivationssprüchen und inspirierenden Anekdoten. Da sieht man, dass sie auch eben viel aus diesen Büchern mitnehmen. Manches lassen sie liegen und manches nehmen sie mit. Einiges davon findet man dann auch in ihrem Buch. Sie haben auch bei Ansprachen mit ihren Spielern schon in die Trickkiste gegriffen. Mit goldenen Handeln, mit zusammengebundenen Stöcken oder sogar einem lebendigen Hansen.
Zum Erfolg gibt es keine Tricks.
Okay, mit Trickkiste meine ich die Zauberkiste. Ich weiß natürlich, wie sie es gemeint haben. Besonders beeindruckt hat mich der lebendige Hase, also Hans der Angsthase, den sie mit in die Kabine genommen haben. Wie findet man bei so etwas die richtige Dosis? Das deuten sie ja auch an. Sie können jetzt nicht bei jedem Spiel kommen und sich irgendwas Neues überlegen, mit dem sie in einem Bild den Spielern etwas mitgeben wollen, was sich dann vor allem in ihrer Haltung auf dem Spielfeld ausdrückt.
Der Trainer Klaus Topmüller war ja ein sehr guter Trainer, ein sehr guter Motivator auch. Der hat in der Kabine bei Eintracht Frankfurt, glaube ich mal, das hat ja auch mit dem Wappen zu tun gehabt, der Eintracht einen Adler mitgebracht. Du kannst sowas – und das fand ich auch gut – Adler im Grunde genommen, edles Tier, steht für Kraft, für Energie, für Durchsetzungsvermögen. Das finde ich auch gut. Nur du kannst solche Dinge auch nur punktuell einsetzen. Das meinte ich ja damit. Du kannst dann – wie willst du das stoppen? In der nächsten Woche bringst du einen Löwen mit und dann irgendwann Elefanten. Solche Dinge werden von uns Trainern punktuell eingesetzt. Und so ist es auch immer wieder wichtig, dass man immer wieder auch mal zusätzlich motiviert durch Metaphern, durch Geschichten, die man erzählt. Aber das kannst du natürlich nur punktuell machen. Denn das Allerwichtigste ist die Eigenmotivation deiner Spieler. Wenn du permanent pushen und fremd motivieren musst, wird die Mannschaft dann irgendwann in sich zusammenfallen. Aber mit Geschichten, mit Metaphern zu arbeiten, um die rechte Gehirnhälfte zu erreichen. Wir haben ja zwei Gehirnhälften, es gibt sogar Wissenschaftler, die sagen drei, aber zwei reichen mir. Eigentlich linke und rechte Gehirnhälfte musst du beide erreichen. Wo die Gefühlswelt sitzt, wo die Intuition sitzt, die Kreativität, die erreichst du nicht mit Zahlen, Daten, Fakten, Statistiken. Die linke Gehirnhälfte wiederum durch diese Dinge, wo der Verstand sitzt, wo das Urteilsvermögen sitzt und so weiter. Und so ist es wichtig, dass man im Grunde genommen, wenn du motivieren willst, auch beide Gehirnhälften anspricht.
Jetzt haben sie ja in ihrem Buch auch ganz viele Gastbeiträge, würde ich sie nennen, von ehemaligen Spielern vermehrt, auch zum Teil noch andere Personen aus ihrem Umfeld, also Benedikt Höwedes, Julian Draxler, Manuel Neuer, Sehat Kolasinac. Also da kann man die ganze Palette sehen und auch einige Namen, die man vielleicht so noch nicht gehört hat. Ist es jetzt Zufall, dass fast jeder von denen ein solches Ereignis hat, was eben oft nicht nur mit etwas verbunden ist, was sie gesagt haben, sondern auch mit etwas, was sie gemacht haben? Haben sie darum gebeten, dass die solche Anekdoten herausholen? Oder ist das dann das, woran sich die Menschen erinnern?
Ich freue mich über diese Frage. Zunächst einmal habe ich die Spieler nur kontaktiert um einen Gastbreitag gebeten. Habe mich dann aber rausgehalten. Und habe zu keinem gesagt, du schreib mal bitte was ganz Tolles über den Trainer, dass ich so richtig gut bei wegkomme. Wenn man das Buch so liest, könnte der Leser ja das ja meinen. Aber dem war nicht so. Ich sagte, schreib bitte ganz frei Dinge, die ihr erlebt habt. Das kann auch was sein, wo die dann sagen, um Himmels Willen, was ist das denn für ein Arschloch dieser Elgert? Also da seid ihr ganz frei drin. Dass sich manche Dinge überlappen, liegt in der Natur der Sache. Dass es auch teilweise unterschiedliche Dinge sind, liegt natürlich auch daran, dass man ihnen nicht in jeder Saison das Gleiche erzählt. Und dass jeder Mensch natürlich die Dinge anders für sich wahrnimmt. Der eine sagt vielleicht, was soll der Quatsch jetzt, da kann ich gar nichts mit anfangen. Und der andere sagt dann, boah, so wie man zum Beispiel sagt, in dem Spiel hätte ich die Welt, hätte ich Bäume ausreißen können. Das ist total individuell.
Aber es ist ja interessant, dass bei den Menschen, dass unser Kopf anscheinend so funktioniert, dass solche Taten, hätte ich es jetzt genannt, also eben ein Hase, der mitgebracht wird in die Kabine oder goldene Hand hin, dass sowas eher hängen bleibt, als auch ein paar Spieler haben auch auf Zitate von ihnen referiert oder auf Gespräche, gerade Benedikt Höwedes. Aber es scheint ja eher zu verfangen, dieses etwas objektifizierte, also dass man etwas mit einem Ding verbindet.
Ja, da ist ja auch jeder Mensch anders. Der eine ist eher eher in Bildern, visuell, und der andere ist eher auditiv, nimmt über die Ohren wahr.
Das sind natürlich alles Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen und – Hörer.
Also das ist auch wieder, wir haben es ja mit, auch wenn in einer Mannschaft die Mannschaft an erster Stelle steht, also dass wir zuerst, haben wir es ja trotzdem mit Individuen zu tun. Also jeder Mensch ist ein Unikat, jeder Mensch ist einmalig. Es gibt keine, glaube ich nicht mal Zwillinge, die den gleichen genetischen Code haben. Und deswegen sind ja auch immer wieder zwei Dinge in der Führung wichtig. Dass wir, dass wir unsere Spieler oder die Menschen, die wir führen auch als Individuen, als Einmaligkeiten anerkennen. Dass wir eben nicht alles über einen Kamm scheren, sondern Gleichbehandlung heißt dann eher, jedem das zu geben, was er braucht. Und da ist jeder einzigartig. Aber jeder Mensch hat auch ein zweites großes Bedürfnis, wir haben viel mehr, ich schätze mal, in der Führung. Jeder möchte eigentlich auch Teil einer gemeinsam größeren Sache sein. Und beide Dinge ist es wichtig, dass man sie in der Menschen- und Mannschaftsführung auch berücksichtigt.
Jetzt haben wir ganz viel über diese weichen Faktoren gesprochen. Menschenführung, wie man individuell erreicht, Motivation. Was ist denn eigentlich Ihre Spielphilosophie? Lassen Sie uns mal über Fußball sprechen. Welchen Fußball wollen Sie spielen lassen?
Ja, Fußball total. Also für mich gibt es jetzt nicht nur den Ballbesitz Fußball oder nur Konterfußball oder nur auf den zweiten Ball gehen, sondern Fußball total. Fußball hat viel mit Situationen zu tun. Also ich habe gerne selber den Ball. Und dann musst du eben die Wege finden, die zum Spielziel eins sind, nämlich Tore zu schießen. Da gibt es eben das Ballbesitzspiel, was wir auch immer versuchen, sehr, sehr gut zu beherrschen. Dass wir versuchen, im Positionsangriff Wege zu finden. Da will ich jetzt aber auch nicht so sehr in die Tiefe gehen. Meine Kollegen hören ja vielleicht auch mit. Aber dass wir immer versuchen, Wege zu finden. Zum Gegner ist ein Tor ganz simpel. Das geht direkt über die Abwehr. Das geht aber vor allen Dingen, indem du immer wieder versuchst, Wege zu finden, hinter die Abwehr zu kommen oder auch zum nächsten Mal da vor, um dann da durchzukommen. Aber dazu gehört natürlich auch das Counterspiel. Dass wir versuchen, durch Gegenpressing, durch Angriffspressing sehr früh und sehr hoch den Ball zu gewinnen, weil wir dann einfach kürzere Wege haben zum gegnerischen Tor. Also ich würde das so als Fußball total bezeichnen. Meine Mannschaft oder wir haben gerne selber den Ball, weil das für mich auch der Ursprung des Spiels ist. Wir sind alle angefangen, keiner ist angefangen, Fußball zu spielen, mal egal wo, weil es so wahnsinnig viel Spaß macht, den Ball hinterherzulaufen. Es macht Spaß, den Ball zu haben. Das heißt, vereinfacht ausgedrückt, attackieren. Wenn wir den Ball haben, das ist gegnerische Tor. Wenn der Gegner den Ball hat, den Ball, damit wir den so schnell wie möglich wieder kriegen. Aber auf der anderen Seite ist die Basis einer ganz starken Offensive auch eine gute Defensive. Dass du als Mannschaft einfach auch kompakt stehen musst, dass du gegnerische Konter im Keime stickst, dass du gemeinsam gut verteidigst, dass du aber auch sehr stark bist in den Basics des Verteidigens und des Angreifens.
Also wenn ich ehrlich bin, überrascht mich die Antwort nicht. Sie wollen Tore schießen und sie wollen Tore verhindern. Ohne, dass sie mir jetzt ihre geheimen Pläne hier offenbar müssen, gibt es ja verschiedene Arten, das zu schaffen.
Das ist nicht so geheim, aber das alleine, da kann man ja nicht so ins Detail gehen. Das würde ja dann schon noch mal ein paar Stunden dauern.
Wir können ja kurze fünf Minuten. Es gibt ja verschiedene Schulen zum Beispiel des Ballbesitzfußballs. Es gibt das klare Positionsspiel, in dem der Ball rotiert, in dem das Bilden von Dreiecken wichtig ist. Das würde ich jetzt mal als spanische Schule bezeichnen. Ein bisschen unscharf, kann man auch noch andere dazu rechnen. Das ist so eine Art und Weise des Ballbesitzfußballs. Dann gibt es ja auch den Ballbesitzfußball, der eher in der letzten Reihe den Ball hat, bis sich beim Gegner einen Raum öffnet, weil der Gegner im Verschieben nicht aufmerksam genug war und dann wird in diesen Raum reingespielt. Welche Philosophie verfolgen Sie da? Steht die dann auch für Schalke 04 als Verein? Oder ist das jetzt einfach etwas, was Sie über die Jahre hinweg entwickelt haben?
Es geht im Fußball gar nicht so sehr um Systeme. Moderner Fußball ist vollkommen systemunabhängig. Es geht im Fußball vielmehr um Prinzipien. Und wenn wir über die Offensive sprechen, dann geht es ja nur darum, wie kommen wir dahin? Da hatte ich ja gerade schon mal gesagt, der erste Ansatz ist natürlich der Ballgewinn, um dann rein kontern zu können. Der Gegner ist offen, ist nicht formiert. Du hast kürzere Wege zum Tor und du musst weniger Gegenspieler überwinden, als wenn der Gegner formiert ist. Und wenn du selber den ballerst, dann gehören diese Prinzipien, aber nicht nur bei mir, die gehören einfach dazu. Es kommt natürlich darauf an, nicht nur Prinzipien zu haben, es kommt darauf an, sie zu trainieren und auch umzusetzen. Solche Dinge wie eine gute Raumaufteilung zu haben. Da haben mich schon die holländische Schule, die Käufschule, aber auch die spanische Schule, Barcelona schon sehr geprägt. Dass die Dreiecksbildung, die Rautenbildung, gehen wir noch einen Schritt weiter, von großer Bedeutung sind. Durch die Raute, gehen wir doch ein bisschen ins Detail, hast du eben viele Dreiecke und optimale Zuspielwinkel. Je mehr Rauten, desto mehr Dreiecke.
Vor allem das Direktspiel kann man dann…
Hast du auf dem Platz. Was wir anstreben durch unser Spiel, ist, wenn wir über die Kette spielen können, das hat ja auch was mit dem Prinzip Packing zu tun, dann haben wir den Gegner komplett ausgespielt. Dann machen wir das. Aber wenn der Gegner fällt, und das machen die ja meistens dann, in dem Moment, wo du diesen langen Ball ansetzt, dann macht das keinen Sinn. Dann ergeben sich für dich aber wieder Räume, in denen die sich fallen lassen, zwischen den Linien. Aber wir versuchen immer wieder so schnell wie möglich, und nicht durch so langen Ballbesitzfußball. Manchmal brauchst du mehr Pässe dafür, zwischen die gegnerischen Linien zu kommen. Und wenn du da bist, dann hast du nur noch vier oder fünf. Je nach Viererkette, manchmal auch Dreierkette, Adi Hütter. Wenn die hochgeschoben sind, sind manchmal nur drei, dann hast du in deinem Halbraum etwas mehr Platz. Dafür hat er aber vorher zwei, die mit attackieren können im Mittelfeld. Wenn wir da drin sind, dann haben wir schon mal etwas ganz Wichtiges erreicht. Und dann möchte ich, dass wir wellenförmig die Schnittstellen belaufen. Die Schnittstellen sind die Abstände zwischen zwei Spielern oder der Abstand zwischen einem Außenverteidiger und der Außenlinie. Dass wir die dann abgestimmt belaufen, dann sind wir ja schon im letzten Rittel. Um dann eben in die Box einzudringen, innen oder außen, je nachdem. Je nachdem, wo sich Platz ergibt. Und Platz ergibt, das Tor steht in der Mitte. Kannst du auch über die Mitte, über die Mittelzone oder über die Halbräume anstreben, aber auch über die Flügel. Und wenn wir möchten, immer möglichst über die Zentrale geht aber nicht immer. Dazu gehört dann eben auch eine gute Ballzirkulation. Du kommst nicht immer sofort zwischen den Linien oder dahinter. Du musst den Ball zirkulieren lassen. Dazu gehört es eben auch, den Gegner auf eine Seite zu locken, um dann die Spielverlagerung einzuleiten auf die andere Seite. Um in der Verlagerung aber musst du die Mitte auch weiter sehen. Weil du musst nicht unbedingt auf die andere Seite. Wenn du den Gegner auf die Seite gezogen hast, fängst du an zu verlagern. Aber die Zentrale geht es ja vielleicht auch da durch.
Das ist der schnellere Weg.
Also bei uns, bei mir, in meiner Philosophie, ist die Defensive sehr stark reglementiert. Sehr stark reglementiert. Trotzdem müssen die Spieler eigene Entscheidungen treffen, weil sie die Entscheidungen immer noch treffen. In der Offensive haben meine Spieler deutlich mehr Freiräume als bei vielen anderen Trainern. Da geht in Deutschland ja die Tendenz wieder so ein bisschen hin. Wir haben eine ganz andere Idee. Wir haben auch Matchpläne. Das musst du haben. Sonst handelst du fahrlässig. Wir wissen genau, wie wir spielen wollen, was wir wollen. Sind da aber auch Systemvariabel. Es gibt ganz einfache Prinzipien, die wir immer wieder haben. Wir wollen zwischen die Reihen, wir wollen dahinter. Wir wollen tiefe Vorbreite. Wir haben auch immer eine Idee, was den Spielaufbau betrifft, was das Übergangsspiel betrifft, das Endspiel betrifft. Endspiel heißt beim Schach. Spiel im letzten Drittel im Fußball. Aber insgesamt gebe ich schon immer meinen Spielern in der Offensive, bei aller Spielidee, die wir haben, deutlich mehr Freiheiten. Weil ich glaube, wenn wir in der Offensive zu sehr reglementieren, zu sehr vorschreiben, töten wir Kreativität und Intuition.
Das ist ja so eine der aktuellen Debatten. Da habe ich jetzt alles nachvollziehen können, was Sie gesagt haben. Sie müssen aber kurz bitte noch erklären, was meinen Sie mit dem wellenartigen Anlaufen der Schnittstellen? Also die Schnittstellen, das ist klar, aber inwiefern in Wellen? Wenn Sie mir das nochmal kurz erklären können.
Wellenförmig insofern, dass nicht alle gleichzeitig die Schnittstellen belaufen. Es ist ja wichtig, dass nicht zwei Spieler die gleiche Schnittstelle belaufen. Einer reicht. Es gibt verschiedene Schnittstellen. Wenn jetzt aber alle gleichzeitig starten, jeder in eine andere Schnittstelle, kann es vorkommen, dass alle gleichzeitig im Abseits stehen.
Okay, also es ist zeitlich gemacht, das Wellenartige.
Es hat mit Abseits zu tun. Es geht aber auch darum, dass es für den Gegner, wenn der Gegner, dass nämlich alle Katzen gleichzeitig in die Schnittstellen werden, die sich fallen lassen. Das sollen die ja nicht. Genau. Wir wollen ja vor der gegnerischen Linie, zum Beispiel frontal, parallel oder diagonal laufen, um dann rein zu starten. Machen das aber alle gleichzeitig. Der Gegner lässt sich fallen. Oder bleibt stehen, sind alle abseits. Oder der Gegner lässt sich eben fallen. Es ist für den Gegner deutlich schwerer zu verteidigen, wenn du in sogenannten Wellen da rein startest. Kann man aber auch sagen, einer nach dem anderen.
Okay, das ist jetzt, da könnte ich jetzt noch ewig mit Ihnen drüber reden, aber da kommen wir, finde ich, auch schon zu einem Kern, der gerade im Nachwuchsfußball dann nochmal interessanter ist als vielleicht im Profifußball. Denn die Basis von all dem, was Sie jetzt beschrieben haben, ist ja zum Beispiel der gut ausgeführte Pass und der gut verarbeitete Pass. Also, dass man es schafft, einen sauberen Pass zu spielen und dass der dann auch so weiterverarbeitet wird, dass ich eben das Feld vor mir habe, die Passoption im besten Fall vielleicht sogar direkt mit einem Kontakt weiter spielen kann. Sind diese Grundlagen alle schon gelegt bei den U19-Spielern, die sie bekommen? Oder ist das auch noch ein wesentlicher Teil ihrer Arbeit, erst mal dieses, ja, tatsächlich einfach das Fundament, auf dem letztlich der Fußball beruht, zu legen?
Also, zunächst mal kann ja jeder Spieler, egal wie alt oder wie gut, das betonen die aber auch selber. Auch die Ronaldos und die Bessies, die wollen immer noch besser werden. Aber das sind auch sehr, sehr gute Trainierer über Jahrzehnte, können immer noch besser werden. Was mir schon auffällt in den letzten Jahren, das Tempo ist höher geworden. Das Taktische ist wichtiger geworden und nicht unbedingt besser. Was aber auffällig ist, ist einfach auch im U19-Bereich die schwache Ballbeherrschung. Und der Ball ist das Spielgerät. Der Ball ist das Spielgerät und das musst du zunächst einmal beherrschen. Erst dann werden alle anderen Dinge wichtig. Das ist genauso wichtig oder vielleicht sogar noch ein Takt wichtiger. Das Spielverständnis, die Spielintelligenz, ist die Entscheidung zu treffen. Denn auf dem Platz, dadurch, dass sich alle Spieler – das ist ja nicht wie beim Schach, obwohl das schon schwer genug ist – alle Spieler bewegen sich ständig durcheinander. Die eigenen, die Gegner. Der Ball bewegt sich auch. Und du musst erkennen, was da passiert. Das meine ich dann auch mit Spielverständnis, Spielintelligenz. Denn nur, wenn du erkennst, was da auf dem Platz abgeht, was da passiert, und mit jeder Bewegung ist schon wieder alles anders, dann verstehst du ja das Spiel. Und nur, wenn du das Spiel verstehst, kannst du eine optimale taktische Entscheidung treffen. Hammerwichtig. Spielverständnis, taktisches Verständnis, Spielintelligenz. Wenn ich jetzt aber den Ball nicht beherrsche, ich habe jetzt eine taktische Entscheidung getroffen, also ich habe gesehen und ich habe verstanden und habe jetzt entschieden, womit ich ausführe, bin aber technisch zu schwach oder kann es nicht mit beiden Füßen. Kann ich keinen Spitzenfußballer sein? Also was ich sagen will, dass Fußball eigentlich ein ganz einfaches Spiel ist. Aber es auf ganz hohem Niveau zu spielen, ist komplex und schwer. Und da müssen wir wieder hin. Da müssen wir wieder hin. Das muss selbstverständlich sein, dass ein U19er oder ein U17er, U15er mit dem Spielgerät umgehen kann. Weil wenn er das nicht kann und der Raum, gehe ich nach Zeitdruck, wird immer größer, dann wird er da oben nicht spielen können. Und da glaube ich einfach, dass Wege gefunden werden müssen, um wieder auf diese vermeintlichen 10.000 Stunden oder zehn Jahre zu kommen. Ich glaube, dass unsere Spieler die noch nicht haben. Ich hatte das aber damals. Weil ich auf der Straße jeden Tag stundenlang gekickt habe. Weil ich Erfahrungen gesammelt habe. Und das jetzt einfach nur so in den Raum zu werfen, hilft ja noch nicht. Wir müssen es in Vereinstraining wieder reinbekommen. Durch Zusatzschichten, durch Veränderungen vielleicht der Ansätze auch im Training. Aber wir brauchen natürlich auch wieder. Wir kriegen ja Bolzplatz-Mentalität nur dadurch, indem wir Ersatz schaffen dafür. Wir sprechen schon lange darüber. Ich spreche schon lange darüber. Ich habe jetzt auch mal von Oliver B aufgehört. Oder von Michael Schönweiß auch vom DFB. Die denken da schon so ähnlich. Ein Ansatz wäre zum Beispiel – und ich glaube sogar, dass der praktikabel ist. Und das nicht nur die Leistungszentren. Auch die kleinen Vereine, die kleinen Gemeinden, da sind oft so tolle Trainer und haben so oft so tolle Plätze. Warum setzen wir da nicht Fußballspielplätze hin? Warum bieten wir nicht ab Mittags zum Beispiel Betreuung an? Da ist einer, der kümmert sich um euch, aber der schreibt euch nicht alles vor. Der kann euch mal Hilfestellung geben, aber der stellt euch Bälle, der stellt euch Trikots zur Verfügung. Wo du Fußballtennis spielen kannst, wo du eins gegen eins, zwei gegen zwei, Minitore, wo du drei gegen drei oder vielleicht auch nur mal auf Dosen, wie früher, wie wir. Wo du aber auch einfach auch ein Tor hast, wo du schießen kannst, wo du Fußballwände hast, wo du aber auch klettern, springen, Koordination usw. machen kannst. Da gibt es ja schon Vereine, die machen sowas, Ansätze. Wäre mal ein Ansatz, um einfach, wie kommst du sonst auf diese Stunden? Kommst du nicht mehr? Und dann wird die Technik auf der Strecke bleiben. Weil du brauchst diese Zeit. Und du lernst als junger Mensch einen Tag schneller. Du kannst dich lebenslang verbessern. Aber du kannst dich in, man spricht ja immer vom goldenen Lernalter um die zwölf Jahre. Das B- und A-Jugendalter ist noch mal ein goldenes Lernalter. Du kannst dich immer weiter verbessern. Aber du brauchst, die müssen wieder auf diese Stunden kommen, sonst wirst du den Ball nicht so beherrschen. Es ist teilweise grausam, sich anzusehen. Wenn der Ball verspringt, das Spielgerät nicht das macht, was du willst, dann hast du, wenn du mit dem Ball kämpfst, wie soll ich dann mit dem Gegner kämpfen? Schaff ich doch gar nicht. Das schließt sich aus.
Also letztlich soll ja wieder mehr Fußball gespielt werden. Würde das dann auch bedeuten, vor allem in jüngerem Alter, also jetzt nicht im U19-Bereich. Sie sind ja der Übergang in den Leistungsbereich. Sie müssen die Spieler vorbereiten, auch dass sie es potenziell schaffen könnten, in den Profibereich zu kommen. Aber in den vorgelagerten Bereichen müsste da nicht vielleicht auch wieder Fußball mehr als Spiel verstanden werden und weniger als wir haben jetzt 3 zu 0 gewonnen oder wir haben 3 zu 4 verloren?
Es gibt ja Ansätze, das Resultat abzuschaffen. Ich kann den Ansatz verstehen. Nur ich bin nicht ganz dabei, weil schon die Kleinsten wollen wissen, wie das Spiel ausgeht.
Irgendjemand zählt immer mehr.
Ja, die wollen wissen, wie das Spiel ausgeht. Ich würde das Resultat beibehalten. Wir müssen da den Druck rausbekommen. Wenn die Kleinsten schon immer extrem Ergebnisdruck haben, natürlich sollen sie gewinnen wollen. Aber wenn da schon Gewinnmüssen dazu kommt – Gewinnen müssen macht immer schwach, Gewinnen wollen macht eher stark – ich würde da so ein bisschen vom Resultatsdruck weggehen. Dazu muss man aber auch dahin kommen, dass die Vereine nicht nur sagen, unsere Trainer haben keinen Resultatsdruck bei den Kleinsten, sondern dass es wirklich auch gelebt wird. Denn die Wahrheit ist doch dann hinterher, wenn der fünfmal verliert, wenn einer hier mit der Schalker D-Jugend fünfmal verliert, dann wird es eben, so sehr man das vorher auch propagiert hat, alles in Frage gestellt. Da sollten wir schon weg vom Resultatsdruck uns viel stärker auf Entwicklung und Prozesse fokussieren. Denn wenn die Spieler sich gemeinsam und individuell weiterentwickeln und verbessern, wirst du automatisch häufiger gewinnen. Aber es muss eben mehr der Umgang mit dem Spielgerät und das Spiel an sich im Vordergrund stehen. Und nicht irgendwelche Spieleideen und Strategien. Mal so ein Beispiel, was auch jeder versteht. Wenn da in der E- und D-Jugend schon extrem Ball verschoben wird, dann ist das natürlich totaler Humbug. Oder wenn sowas dann auch noch trainiert wird, anstatt sich fußballisch zu verbessern.
Na gut, man kann das verschieben in der Kette, aber das bringt halt noch nicht den Rest mit.
Das Verschieben machen die in der E- und D-Jugend von alleine, weil immer noch alle zum Ball fließen. Die Ballorientierung ist automatisch da.
Sie haben ja auch in Ihrem Buch geschrieben, Zitat, um schnell nach oben zu kommen, stehen im Kinder- und Jugendfußball häufig auch Spieleidee, Taktik und Matchplan zu sehr im Vordergrund. Das ist das, was Sie gerade gesagt haben. Vernachlässigt werden dadurch Technik, Kreativität und Spielfreude. Und da musste ich spontan einmal mit Joel denken, der das ja in anderen Worten, in etwas markigeren Worten, mit das heutzutage die Kinder, wenn sie Fußball gelernt haben, mit zwölf Systeme rückwärts furzen können, aber keinen Ball behandeln können. Das ist doch im Grunde genau die gleiche Kritik, nur nochmal anders formuliert.
Ja, ich sehe es differenzierter, weil er hat ja so, glaube ich, großen Respekt vor ehemals Fußballspieler, auch was seine Ansätze betrifft. Ich sehe es teilweise auch so wie er, nur nicht vollständig. Also mir ist es immer zu sehr schubladend denken, wenn man alle Jugendtrainer heute dann als Laptoptrainer bezeichnet. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob er das so genau getan hat, aber es ging ja ein bisschen in die Richtung. Also es gibt da unter den Jugendtrainer schon hervorragende Profitrainer, aber auch hervorragende Jugendtrainer. In einer Sache bin ich natürlich dabei. Das hatte ich ja gerade auch gesagt, dass es Altersstufen gibt, in denen diese hochtaktischen Dinge unwichtig sind und sich sogar entwickeln mit den Jahren. Indem du implizit schulst, das heißt, mehr durch Spielformen, mehr begleitet, statt im Profibereich wird explizit trainiert. Klar, dass du mehr coachen musst, dass du mehr anleitest, dass du deine Vorstellung rüberbringst. Im Kinder- und Jugendbereich sollte mehr implizit trainiert werden, das heißt, mehr begleitet, den Ball noch mehr in den Vordergrund stellen, über Spielformen Dinge anstreben, ihnen nicht alles vorgeben. Wenn du zum Beispiel das 1-2-Kontaktspiel forcieren willst, muss man in den Altersstufen nicht unbedingt. Das ist nur ein Beispiel. Dann kann ich auch Spielformen den Spielern an die Hand geben, wo das automatisch sich ergibt. Oder ich kann sagen, ich erwarte von euch, dass ihr mit 1-2 Kontakt spielt. Das ist dann wieder explizit. Mehr Freiheiten lassen, mehr Spielformen, mehr sogenannte Small-Sided Games hat extrem viele Vorteile. Ein großer Vorteil ist zum Beispiel, wird die Technik gleich wieder mit trainiert. Mehr Ballkontakte. 11 gegen 11 sagen die Leute, die das untersucht haben. Zwei Ballkontakte vielleicht in einer Minute, wenn überhaupt. Sechs gegen sechs, vier. Vier gegen vier, sechs Kontakte. Mehr Ballkontakte, mehr Entscheidungen treffen. Und wenn ich in vier gegen vier spiele, oder in fünf gegen fünf, habe ich auch schon hochtraktische Dinge mit drin. Wie zum Beispiel, was die Offensive betrifft, Dreiecksbildung, Rautenbildung hat auch da Vorteile. Kann man sich aber gemeinsam erarbeiten. Durch Guided Discovery viele Fragen stellen. Aber in vielen Bereichen bin ich da schon, bin ich da sehr bei eben nicht in allen. Muss ja auch nicht sein.
Und ist das eine Diskussion, die jetzt auf ihrer Ebene der Trainer – Sie sind ja auch sicher gut vernetzt – geführt wird? Denn ich habe das Gefühl, das poppt immer mal wieder so auf. Und das wird dann immer auch aufgehängt, vor allem am Abschneiden der deutschen Vereine und der Nationalmannschaft. Und dann kommt auch ein Oliver Bierhoff und sagt, wir wollen jetzt mehr Ballplatz-Mentalität, wir wollen Kreativität fördern, wir wollen wieder schnellere Spieler haben. Und dann wirkt das auf mich immer, als wäre dann damit die Diskussion, die eigentlich gar keine war, beendet.
Das wird man sehen. Ich hatte ein langes Gespräch über zwei Stunden mit dem Michael Schönwald, Chefausbilder jetzt beim DFB, den ich fachlich und menschlich auch sehr schätze. Also die Ansätze, die finde ich schon hochspannend. Ich gehe jetzt nicht in allen Dingen mit. Zum Beispiel, wenn es um Resultate geht in verschiedenen Alterstufen. Aber es ist, glaube ich, auch zunächst mal zur Diskussion gebracht worden. Das sind ja Ansätze, die sie haben. Ich weiß nicht, inwieweit sie dann schon beschlossen sind, was dann kommen wird. Aber eins bin ich dabei. Das müssen wir abwarten. Wissen ist wenig, können ist König. An ihren Taten sollst du sie erkennen. Warten wir mal ab.
Ja, ich stelle mir da ehrlich gesagt immer eine übergeordnete Frage. Wenn es heißt, es soll wieder mehr Kreativität im Fußball gefördert werden, dann bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher, ob – ich sage jetzt einfach mal der Deutsch, auch wenn es den Deutsch nicht gibt – aber Journalisten, Fans und zum Teil vielleicht auch Trainer, ob wir das überhaupt aushalten. Denn zur Kreativität gehören ja immer die Dinge, die nicht geklappt haben, genauso mit dazu. Also die drei ersten Pässe können fürchterlich schiefgehen und alle im Stadion stöhnen auf. Und dann würde es ja bedeuten, dass wir alle wollen, dieser Spieler soll jetzt bitte nochmal den vierten Pass passieren, denn Kreativität ist ja nicht über 90 Minuten da. Kreativität sind einzelne Momente. Und ich weiß gar nicht, ob der Fußball so wie er heutzutage analysiert und seziert wird, auch von Leuten wie mir im Rasenfunk, ob das überhaupt noch eine Projektionsfläche ist, wo man das wirklich aushält, dass jemand kreativ ist, dass wir ihm auch mal zugestehen, dass er um konventionelle Wege geht, auch wenn er die ersten vier Mal gegen die Tür läuft, und beim fünften Mal geht er dann erst durch.
Bin ich dabei? Bin ich voll bei Ihnen? Es muss nach wie vor erfolgreich sein oder noch erfolgreicher. Und wir müssen auch nicht alles verteufeln, denn selbstverständlich gehört ein Matchplan heute. Gehört eine Spielidee dazu. Aber ich finde, das Ganze sollte sich vor allen Dingen aufbauen aufgrund, zunächst einmal die erste Säule müsste sein, die eigene Stärken. Die eigenen Stärken. Wir müssen den Gegner analysieren. Wir müssen die Schwächen und Stärken des Gegners können, um Gegenstrategien zu entwickeln. Aber ich halte es für viel wichtiger, wie spielen wir? Was ist unser Spiel? Wie wollen wir uns durchsetzen? Das hat natürlich mit den Stärken und Schwächen des Gegners zu tun. Das schließt sich aber nicht aus. Aber eines ist doch klar. Wir dürfen natürlich auch nicht schulen, dass der Innenverteidiger sich hinten den Ball nimmt. Wir sollen jetzt kreativ und mutig sein. Und jetzt mache ich den mal alle frisch und haue den rein. Oder ich spiele jetzt nur noch Risikopässe in der Spieleröffnung. Damit spiele ich dem Gegner von fünf Pässen vier in den Konter rein. Trotzdem müssen wir natürlich hingehen und auch am Beispiel des Innenverteidigers das durchaus mal einfordern, dass der den Ball zwischen die näggegegnischen Reihen durchpeitscht. Aber dann wird es ja schon wieder taktisch. Wie stehst du dann als Formation? Voraussetzung dafür ist natürlich dann, dass du zwar so viel Tiefe wie möglich im Spiel hast, aber nur so viel Breite wie nötig. Und wenn der diesen Risikoball durch zwei, durch dieses Nadelöhr durchpeitscht und du verlierst den Ball, dass du sofort wieder in die Chance des Gegenpressing gehst. Denn dann ist so ein Ballverlust ja vielleicht sogar ein Vorteil. Aber wir müssen beides schulen. Risiko ja, aber wo befinde ich mich auf dem Feld und wie gehe ich mit diesem Risiko um? Also ich kann ja nicht jetzt zum Innenverteidiger sagen, noch mal gerade, du gehst jetzt nur volles Risiko oder der Außenverteidiger oder der Sechser. Der fängt jetzt nur noch an. Aber wir müssen auch mal in der Spieleröffnung, im Übergangsspiel ein höheres Risiko gehen. Du musst dich nur klug verhalten, damit du nicht jedes Mal den Kontakt kriegst und kriegst die Bude voll dahin. Das werden die Zuschauer nicht mitmachen, das werden die Medien nicht mitmachen. Das schließt aber nicht aus, dass wir Kreativität fördern, dass wir Intuition fördern, dass ein Spieler sich traut, auf dem Platz, auch im Mittelfeld, was Verrücktes zu machen. Aber das eben nicht permanent. Jetzt muss ja nicht jeder gleich im Umkehrschloss, wo er sich bewegt, seine Pirouetten machen. Aber im letzten Drittel…
Es gibt eben Ort für Kreativität, das ist eben das letzte Drittel.
Ja, das finde ich sehr gut.
So ein bisschen wie der Bastelraum im Kindergarten.
Ich kann ja auch hinten mal kreativ sein, ohne jetzt ein übergroßes Risiko einzugehen. Aber Risiko, Mut eigentlich überall, mit Abstrichen hinten und im defensiven Mittelfeld. Aber vorne müssen sie sich einfach trauen. Und ich glaube einfach, dass das auch ein bisschen mit unserer Philosophie zu tun hat. Dass hier viele Kreativspieler rausgekommen sind. Nicht nur Leroy, Julian Draxler. Er ist mir ein bisschen zu sehr davon abgekommen. Ich würde gerne sehen, dass er auch bei Paris wieder mehr in sein Dribbling reingeht. Weil das ist eine große Stärke. Max Meyer. Und sicherlich noch der eine oder andere mehr. Auch Manuel Neuer ist ein Kreativtorwart. Der traut sich was. Da müssen wir wieder hin, dass sich Spieler einfach trauen, dass du das sogar einforderst. Und so ein bisschen bei der U21 meine ich, ich habe nicht viel gesehen, weil ich im Urlaub war, konnte man es sehen. Dass man eben wirklich drauf geht. Dass man durch ein gewonnenes 1 gegen 1 oder 2 Spieler hinter sich lässt, der Gegner anfangen muss zu springen, neue Spielsituationen schafft. Es geht eben nicht nur mit passend, passend, passend, passend.
Ja, das konnte man tatsächlich bei dieser U21 EM betrachten. Aber wenn Sie jetzt hier schon Spieler wie eben Leroy Sané, Misut Özil und so weiter, Max Maier nennen, haben Sie denn eine Idee, wie viele Spieler, die jetzt in diesen, Sie gehen jetzt in Ihre 24. Saison als U19-Trainer, ich, ich, Ja, wenn man die Co-Trainerzeit unter Frank Neubert mit dazuzählt. Das ist ja so ein bisschen so eine Dreiviertelsaison, die fehlt.
Also eine Schwangerschaft.
Runden wir ab, sagen wir einfach 23 Jahre. Es ist ja trotzdem sehr, sehr lange. Haben Sie denn eine Idee, wie viele Spieler da durch ihre Hände gegangen sind, die mindestens ein Erstligaspiel gemacht haben?
Wir sind keine Statistiker, aber es sind verdammt viele.
Es sind 105 Spieler, die insgesamt fast auf 4.400 Erstligapartien kommen. Und jetzt nur erste Fußball-Bundesliga. Ich habe jetzt nicht noch internationale.
Danke für Ihre Recherche. Ich bin kein Statistiker, aber das freut mich natürlich sehr und nicht schlecht. Ich hätte es so bei 80 eingestuft.
Nein, es sind tatsächlich 105. Ich habe da noch für ein paar Vergleichsvereine…
Das müssen wir veröffentlichen.
Das können Sie wegen mir sehr gerne machen. Wenn Sie noch einen Link zu dieser Folge mit dazu packen, dann kriege ich ein bisschen Aufmerksamkeit. Ich habe das Ganze noch verglichen mit den Jugendabteilungen vom VfB Stuttgart, FC Bayern, Borussia Dortmund, HSV und Hertha BSC. Ich habe das nicht für alle Jugendabteilungen gemacht, aber für die sechs. Da habe ich einen interessanten Trend festgestellt. Zum einen gibt es tatsächlich noch eine Mannschaft, die mehr Spieler in der Zeit vorgebracht hat. Das ist der VfB Stuttgart. 115 Spieler mit 6.800 Spielern. Die hatten einen sehr guten Lauf in der Jugendarbeit. Aber was allen Mannschaften gemein ist, die diesen genannten, ist, dass es wesentlich zurückgegangen ist. Wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel auf die letzten zehn Jahre gucke, also bis zum Jahr 1991 bei den Spielern, dann kommen sie immer noch auf 38 Spieler, die Erstligaspiele gemacht haben, auch über 1000 Spiele. Also da sind noch sehr viele mit dabei. Und wenn ich jetzt aber auf die letzten fünf Jahre gucke, dann gibt es noch Positivbeispiele wie zum Beispiel Schalke 04 mit 16 Spielern und 217 Spielen, wie zum Beispiel auch Dortmund mit 12 Spielern und 229 Spielen. Da waren dann schon so einzelne Karrieren mit dabei. Aber zum Beispiel gibt es da auch einen FC Bayern, die haben zwar 17 Spieler in die erste Liga gebracht in diesem Zeitraum, nominell am meisten, aber diese Spieler haben 51 Spiele.
Habe ich das jetzt richtig verstanden, dass der Trend eher unseren Weg verstärkt?
Genau. Der Trend ist so, dass es bei allen Vereinen, auch Schalke, zurückgeht, was die eingesetzten Spieler gibt, die eben durch die U19 gelaufen sind und dann in der ersten Liga debütiert haben. Das Schalke aber noch zusammen mit – ich würde da jetzt den BVB dazurechnen, wenn man möchte den VfB noch dazurechnen, da liegt es aber ehrlich gesagt an drei, vier Einzelkarrieren. Aber Schalke ist noch der Vereine, der diesem Trend noch am ehesten widersteht, dass er eben rückgängig ist. Aber bei allen Vereinen ist zu sehen, es geht zurück, dass eigene Jugendspieler entweder in der eigenen Mannschaft oder irgendwo beim Erstligateam Spielminuten bekommen. Woran, würden Sie sagen, liegt das?
Woanders kann ich natürlich nicht einschätzen. Bei uns in den letzten Jahren – jetzt muss ich selber mal ein bisschen nachdenken und zurückgehen, waren es jetzt die letzten waren – Gotuchu, Bourgelap, McKennie. Sicherlich, meiner Meinung nach, und ich darf das auch öffentlich tun, oder habe ich schon immer getan, haben wir zu viele Eigengewächse abgegeben, die…
Noch im Status des Eigengewächses?
Ja, auch danach, die aber alle natürlich schon in dieser Statistik zu finden sind, wie Thilo Kehrer und so weiter, die nicht mehr bei uns spielen. Aber im Moment sind wir da noch ganz gut dabei. Woanders kann ich das nicht einschätzen. Ich werde gleich mal ein bisschen ausführlicher. Wir haben in den letzten Jahren sicherlich einiges mit den gerade genannten Spielern geschafft. Wir haben unser Soll, wobei das schwierig ist, es gibt eben unterschiedliche Jahrgänge, immer noch erfüllt. Wir haben in den letzten zwei, drei Jahren, ohne da jetzt irgendwo Nachzugarten oder irgendjemanden anzupangern, da werde ich auch niemanden wörtlich nennen, widerspricht unseren Prinzipien, etwas zu wenig getan. Wir haben uns zu sehr darauf verlassen, dass auf die Draxlers, Neuers, die ja auch hier nach oben gekommen sind und haben aber zu wenig getan in Sachen Quereinsteiger. Von den anderen gab es noch jede Menge Karneiern und und und Quereinsteiger, Mesut Özil, Sehat Kolasinac, Wes McKennie, da haben wir zu wenig getan. Da ist inzwischen aber die Bereitschaft wieder deutlich höher, mehr zu tun. Bevor ich hinaus will, alle, die mal Bundesliga gespielt haben, haben alle irgendwo mal vorher Jugend gespielt. Daraus ergibt sich für mich eigentlich eine ganz einfache Rechnung. Irgendwo müssen die ja herkommen und dann ist es doch besser, wenn du sie selber ausbildest, ob sehr früh oder später dazu holst und ihnen dann den allerletzten Schliff gibst. Das ist immer noch besser, weil erstens kostengünstiger. Zweitens ist die Identifikation mit Spielern, die aus den eigenen Reihen kommen, häufig noch mal ein bisschen größer. Es hat also nur Vorteile. Warum das rückläufig ist, weiß ich nicht. Bei uns, wenn sie mich jetzt fragen würden, warum, weshalb, einen Stein der Weisen habe ich nicht, immer noch nicht gefunden. Ich weiß eher, dass ich nichts weiß. Ich glaube aber, manchmal ist es so, weil wir schon dazu stehen sollten, bei aller Demut, wir sind da nicht besser oder wir heben uns nicht über andere, weil andere bilden ähnlich oder genauso gut teilweise sogar besser aus. Aber wenn – eine andere Erklärung habe ich auch nicht – wenn besondere Umstände und Menschen aufeinandertreffen, dann kann sowas mal passieren. Schauen Sie mal, wenn Sie sich mit dem Buch – das werden Sie garantiert, vielleicht haben Sie sogar gelesen – von dem englischen Tischtennisspieler Bounce. Das gibt es auch in Deutsch. Der hat sich sehr stark mit Talent und so weiter befasst. Es ist immer wieder spannend – vielleicht schauen Sie mal rein – dass es immer wieder Akademien gibt, wo erstaunlich viele – kann keiner so richtig erklären – gibt es nur Ansätze. Im Tischtennis gab es zum Beispiel eine Straße in England, wo mit Abstand die meisten Tischtennisspieler aus England herkamen. So etwas gibt es scheinbar auch im Fußball.
Es gibt ja auch die berühmten goldenen Jahrgänge, wo dann mit einem Mal fünf Nachwuchsspieler im Profifußball landen. Dann kommt der nächste Jahrgang, wo dann wieder das normale Eintritt, nämlich dass es nur ein bis zwei schaffen. Dann wird das aber so interpretiert, als wäre einmal besonders gute Arbeit gemacht worden und einmal besonders oder nicht ganz so gut. Aber gut, da sind wir uns, glaube ich, sowieso beide einig. Da müssen wir nicht tiefer drauf eingehen. Aber was mich da interessieren würde, ist, eine Komponente gibt es natürlich, die sich jetzt in den letzten fünf bis vielleicht zehn Jahren verändert hat. Nämlich, es gibt ein paar neue – ja, Neudeutsch würde man sagen – Player auf dem Nachwuchsmarkt. Also wir haben zum Beispiel mit der TSG aus Hoffenheim, wenn ich auf die Spieler der letzten fünf Jahre blicke, muss ich die eigentlich mit berücksichtigen. Es ist eigentlich nicht ganz richtig, dass ich die hier rauslasse. Wir haben zum Beispiel mit Rasenballspot Leipzig einen neuen Player, der zwar aus der eigenen Jugend jetzt noch nicht so wahnsinnig viel in den Profifußball gebracht hat, aber da könnten wir ja dann die Jugend, da können wir ja dann Liefering und Salzburg und so weiter, müsste man da eigentlich mit in die Betrachtung mit einbeziehen. Was hat sich denn da verändert? Jetzt wenn wir nur mal auf den Nachwuchsfußball in Deutschland gucken, in den letzten Jahren, hat da so auch so ein Verein wie Schalke auch damit zu tun, dass es da jetzt einfach auch andere Konzepte gibt, andere Angebote und sich die regionale Strahlkraft ein bisschen verschiebt?
Der Konkurrenzkampf war immer schon sehr groß, auch in den Jahren, wo mehr Topspieler rausgekommen sind. Aber er hat sich definitiv natürlich nochmal verstärkt. Also der Kampf – es sind ja in erster Linie Menschen, das hört sich schrecklich an – der Kampf um die Talente, der Wettbewerb um die Talente, aber auch um Vereinserfolg, der hat sich natürlich nochmal deutlich verstärkt. Einmal dadurch, dass das Ausland auch verstärkt in diesen Bereichen aktiv geworden ist, England, Frankreich, wo man im Moment ja auch sehr erfolgreich ist, aber vor allen Dingen natürlich auch national. Haben Sie ja gerade schon gesagt, der Vereine, die häufig gar nicht genannt werden, Wolfsburg im Jugendbereich, die durch die großen Leistungszentren, durch immer mehr Internatsplätze, die müssen natürlich auch gefüllt werden. Und Spieler werden teilweise immer früher auch in die Leistungszentren geholt, teilweise viel zu früh. Hat aber eben damit zu tun, dass die Vereine sagen, wenn wir es nicht tun, dann machen es die anderen. Da gibt es ja zu wenig Agremens dann in diesen Bereichen, was die Altersstufen betrifft. Aber Sie haben es gerade schon gesagt, Hoffenheim ist dazugekommen, Leipzig ist dazugekommen mit hervorragenden Möglichkeiten, Infrastrukturen, aber auch mit entsprechend interessanten Philosophien. Und da sind ja jetzt nur einige wenige. Wir könnten ja, glaube ich, noch viele mehr nennen. Wir haben hier bei uns in der Gegend zum Beispiel auch MSV Duisburg VfL Bochum, die jedes Jahr mitmischen auch in der A- und B-Jugendbundesliga, die hervorragend ausbilden und dir auch was zu bieten haben. Kein Bayern München, kein Borussia Dortmund, kein Schalke 04 ist ja der Nabel der Welt. Das Angebot der Vereine ist erstklassig und da muss jeder Verein eben seinen eigenen Weg finden. Aber du hast eben nicht die Garantie, weil du das und das hast, dass du jetzt alle Spieler bekommst. Man muss sich da auch in anderen Dingen unterscheiden. Und da bin ich immer wieder für den, mögen andere aber auch tun, für den sehr ganzheitlichen Ansatz. Das ist definitiv kein Zufall. Aber ich könnte es ihnen jetzt auch nicht sagen im Detail. Ich habe auch nur Vermutung. Warum gelingt es uns hier immer wieder. Dass Spieler sehr früh eine gute Rolle spielen können in der ersten Mannschaft? Jetzt ist es im Moment im letzten Jahr natürlich leichter gewesen. Ganz klar, dann ist es dann schwerer, eben bei Bayern zu spielen. Aber warum haben so viele geschafft? Da hat man ja selber auch nur Ansätze. Sobald man dann nämlich meint, wir haben es gefunden, dann ist man weg vom Fenster. Aber immer wieder der ganzheitliche Ansatz, immer wieder für die Spieler da sein, ihnen alles geben, was du hast, immer wieder auf allerhöchstem Niveau, in sämtlichen Bereichen arbeiten und trainieren, selbstverständlich, aber auch immer wieder es ihnen schwer machen. Denn Allianz Arena zu spielen oder in Dortmund oder in Leipzig zu spielen, ist sau schwer. Und wenn es vorher leicht war, wie willst du das Schwere denn dann schaffen?
Wie wichtig ist denn da das sportliche Abschneiden der Herrenmannschaft für jetzt zum Beispiel, um Spieler davon zu überzeugen, auch jetzt zum Beispiel zu U19 von Schalke 04 zu kommen? Macht sich da so eine sportliche Misere wie jetzt in der letzten Saison, wenn das anhalten würde, würde sich sowas bemerkbar machen?
Spielschwierigkeit hat keine große Rolle, weil im Grunde genommen bin ich schwächer, die Profi-Mannschaft, umso leichter kommste da rein.
Also es geht eher um die Durchlässigkeit, dass man nachweisen kann, vor dir haben.
Ja, es geht um die Durchlässigkeit. Es geht ein großer Vorteil. Es ist sicherlich, dass wir sagen können, wie viele Spieler es hier schon geschafft haben. Und nochmal bei aller Bescheidenheit ein kleiner Vorteil bin ich dann auch noch da, betone aber immer wieder, dass die Knappenschmiede keine One-Man-Show ist. Wir haben viele sehr, sehr gute Mitarbeiter und Trainer. Aber Liga-Zugehörigkeit könnte noch eine große Rolle spielen. Da ist die erste Liga vielleicht schon wichtig. Aber entscheidend ist, was ist da passiert in den vergangenen Jahren? Und wie will der Verein das auch weiterhin? Und da ist sicherlich das Überzeugendste immer noch der Erfolg der letzten Jahre. Was ist da passiert? Denn du kannst viel erzählen, aber das ist viel, viel wichtiger.
Und das ist jetzt der heilige Grala. Bin ich gespannt, ob sie mir das jetzt erklären können. Warum gibt es auf Schalke immer so hohe Höhen und so tiefe Tiefen?
Profimannschaft, boah, in den letzten Jahren, also Höhen und Tiefen. Es gab ja schon mal verdammt viele Jahre, die extrem gut waren, hier auch bei uns. Viele Jahre hintereinander. Der Anspruch ist, sobald es anfängt zu laufen, wird immer höher. Das war ja damals Vizemeisterschaft und waren dann auf einmal schon wieder nichts. Was wären wir froh, jetzt, vor zwei Jahren, waren wir es, mit dem Misserfolgsjahr des letzten Jahres. Also Schalke 04 hat eine lange, lange Tradition. Und man ist früher, ganz früher, ganz oft Deutscher Meister geworden. Und ich glaube, die Leute sehnen sich sowas von extrem danach, dass man immer wieder, jetzt haben wir es, und dann wieder nicht. Einmal Vize damals, wo Mikos Lombka fast Deutscher Meister geworden wäre, mit großem Vorsprung dann hinterher noch zurückgefallen. Die Leute sehnen sich sehr danach, sowas mal wieder zu erleben. Ja, ich glaube, dass wir hier, ich schätze unseren Menschen, ich gehöre selber dazu, wobei ich eigentlich nicht in solchen Kategorien denke, eher als Kosmopolit, aber ich bin hier geboren, gerne geboren, stehe auch dazu, bin auch stolz darauf. Man neigt hier eher, vielleicht der Deutsche im Allgemeinen, aber auch immer wieder zu himmelhoch jauchzend und zu Tode betrübt. Das wird zu sehr, wenn es hier mal negativ läuft, dass es extrem verstärkt wird durch Öffentlichkeit, durch Medien auch. Und dass wir sobald es anfängt zu laufen, dann meint man sofort wieder so, jetzt haben wir es, so ein bisschen mehr dazwischen uns bewegen und nicht so sehr den Misserfolg und den Erfolg überhöhen, würde uns hier, glaube ich, gut tun. Aber vielleicht wäre Schalker noch nicht mehr Schalker.
Das kann natürlich sein, ja. Und das ist ja auch ein bisschen bezeichnend für unsere Zeit. Glauben Sie denn, dass dieses Malocher-Image, was Sie vorhin auch ganz am Anfang haben Sie auch mal darauf referiert und das Sie wollen auch sehen von Ihren Spielern, dass Sie alles gegeben haben auf dem Platz, steht das vielleicht Schalke 04 als Verein manchmal auch im Weg, weil das in der Kader-Zusammenstellung solche Spielertypen bevorzugt und man vielleicht aber beides braucht, also sowohl denjenigen, der richtig malochen kann, als auch die feine Klinge. Und es gibt eben ganz selten die Spieler, wo beides zusammenkommt.
Ja, aber eines sollte doch selbstverständlich sein. Ich glaube gar nicht mal so, dass diejenigen, die dafür zuständig waren für die Einkäufe oder sind, dass die so sehr in diesen Kategorien gedacht haben. Jetzt stelle ich mal die rhetorische Frage, die ich ja von alleine beantworte. Ist es nicht für jeden Fußballer, selbst wenn er in der Kreisliga spielt und dann erst recht für einen Bundesligaspieler, der Millionen verdient, ist es nicht selbstverständlich, sich jeden Tag den Arsch aufzureißen, auf den Platz zu gehen, sich maximal anzustrengen, 100 Prozent zu geben für seinen Club, für die Fans, die der Club ja sind, für seine Mannschaft, für sich selber. Das schließt sich doch nicht aus. Du brauchst doch jede Mannschaft. Wenn du Erfolg haben willst, brauchst du eine gesunde Mischung. Aber jeder sollte doch alles geben. Auch der Feingeist auf dem Platz sollte nach dem Spiel vom Platz gehen. Und ich habe auf meine Art alles gegeben. Was du natürlich brauchst – vielleicht hilft uns das jetzt auch weiter – ist eine gute Mischung. Und die hatten wir in der letzten Saison hier definitiv nicht.
Also eine Mischung an Spielertypen oder eine Mischung an Persönlichkeiten?
Eine Mischung an Persönlichkeiten, die Verantwortung übernehmen. Aber eine Persönlichkeit ist für mich dann auch nur einer, der für seinen Club, für seinen Arbeitgeber, für sein Team, für sich selber, für die Fans dann eben auch bereit ist, immer wieder alles zu geben. Es sind ja viel zu viele Pseudo-Profis auf dem Platz. Ein Profi wirst du ja nicht, indem du einen Vertrag unterschreibst und indem du viel Geld verdienst. Ein Profi bist du durch dein Verhalten. Hier bin ich allerdings bei ihnen auch. Die Mischung im letzten Jahr, die stimmte nicht. Wir hatten zu wenige Führungsspieler. Wir hatten sicherlich auch zu wenig Geschwindigkeit vorne. Wir hatten zu wenige Spieler, die vorne ein 1 gegen 1 auflösen können. Wir hatten zu wenige Spieler, die Verantwortung übernommen haben. Wir hatten zu wenige Spieler. Wir hatten sie. Nicht falsch verstehen. Wenn das jetzt jemand hört, sollen die das auch richtig verstehen. Wir hatten sie. Aber Spieler, die wirklich alles gegeben haben. Wir hatten sie. Aber zu wenig. Da hoffe ich natürlich auch, dass das in der nächsten Saison wieder besser wird. Bin ich optimistisch.
Ich glaube, mit dieser Hoffnung sind sie jetzt gerade hier im unmittelbaren Umkreis nicht alleine. Da hat ja auch Huub Stevens gerade in seiner Zeit als Interimstrainer sehr vielsagende Andeutungen gemacht. Und ich glaube, auf die letzte Saison bezogen wäre die Frage, die sie gestellt haben, gar nicht so rhetorisch wie jetzt im Allgemeinen bezogen. Ich hatte einen VfB Stuttgart, also einen Journalisten, der sich mit dem VfB Stuttgart befasst, in meinem Saisonrückblick zu Gast. Und der hat den Abstieg des VfB unter anderem darauf zurückgeführt, dass er gesagt hat, die soziale Komponente im Scouting würde seiner Meinung nach beim VfB vernachlässigt. Ich möchte jetzt nicht von Ihnen, dass Sie über den VfB urteilen, das brauchen wir nicht. Aber ich habe mir die Frage gestellt, trifft das vielleicht auch, wenn wir uns jetzt die letzte Saison anschauen, auf Schalke 04 zu?
Vielleicht. Vielleicht. So tief bin ich nicht drin. Aber ich habe da schon auch einen gewissen Ansatz. Früher hat es nur menschliches Scouting gegeben. Das heißt, die Scouts haben sich das Spiel angeschaut mit ihren Augen. Dann ist der Trainer hingefahren, dann ist noch jemand hingefahren. Und das war im Grunde nur ein reines, reines Augenscouting über Fußballwissende, über Erfahrung, welche Philosophie haben wir, hat man sich den Spieler angesehen. Ist im Idealfall auch nochmal zum Training gefahren, hat sich angeschaut, wie trainiert er. Weil im Training kannst du ganz viel sehen. Wenn ich den fünfmal im Training sehe und er ist zweimal stinkgefaul, dann weiß ich schon, der könnte für uns wahrscheinlich nicht geeignet sein. Das hat sich aber alles extrem entwickelt, über andere Sportarten. American Football, Rugby, Baseball, mir fällt jetzt nur ein, aus Moneyball. Da hat man dann stark angefangen, FC mit Jutland in Dänemark. Das Video-Scouting ist immer wichtiger geworden, aber auch das Scouting nach Zahlen, Daten, Fakten, Statistiken. Wenn du in der heutigen Zeit nur eins machst von diesen beiden Dingen, also Zahlen, Daten, Fakten, Statistiken oder nur Schauen, dann verhältst du dich dumm, weil du alle Ressourcen nutzen musst. Jetzt sage ich ja nur vielleicht. Dann musst du die Dinge zusammenbringen. Der Mensch programmiert ja auch immer noch. Der bleibt immer noch das Wichtigste. Du musst Zahlen, Daten, Fakten, Statistiken unbedingt nutzen, sonst handelst du fahrlässig. Aber wenn dadurch der Mensch in seiner Beobachtung, in dem, was er sieht, also live, weil die Zahlen sehen nicht, was geht in dem Spieler vor, ist er jetzt faul gerade, oder wie haut er sich rein gegen den genteilischen Spielmacher, welche Körpersprache hat der gerade, das kannst du nicht erfassen. Du musst im Grunde genommen in einem gesunden, guten Scouting beides tun. Beide Ressourcen nutzen, die Maschine, die Zahlen, die Daten, die Fakten, aber auch den Menschen.
Okay, und das ist dann quasi die Fußballpersönlichkeit und zu der gibt es ja aber auch noch eine Persönlichkeit, die sich auch neben dem Feld zeigt. Wie wichtig sollten dann im Scouting auch Einzigesprächen mit den Spielern sein oder eben dieses Kennenlernen? Ist das vielleicht noch so eine unterschätzte Fähigkeit, weil man sich heutzutage vielleicht an einem anderen Punkt schon für einen Spieler entscheidet und dann in eine andere Art von Gespräch geht?
Das hat Otto Rehagel ja mit seiner Beate damals schon immer vorbildlich gemacht, dass die alle Neuzugänge auch persönlich kennengelernt haben. Ich hoffe, es machen heute auch noch alle, weil letztendlich ist auch in diesem Bereich für mich Face-to-Face immer noch wichtiger als Facebook, weil nur wenn ich Menschen in die Augen schaue, so wie jetzt bei Ihnen, dann kann ich dann, wenn die Augen der Spiegel zur Seele sind, das kann ich nicht durch Zahlen, Daten, Fakten sehen. Das kann ich nur in einem persönlichen Gespräch. Indem ich Fragen stelle, indem ich mich für ihn interessiere, da kommt dann schon einiges raus. Und wenn du erfahren bist und wenn du eine gute Menschen kennennisst hast, dann spürst du schon, macht er dir was vor oder? Also, die Persönlichkeit, der Charakter, immer noch das Wichtigste. Das heißt jetzt nicht, die müssen auf dem Platz schon Drecksäcke sein kann. Aber ich finde, dass sie sich nicht ausschließen, ein anständiger Mensch und ein guter Fußballer zu sein.
Jetzt bekommen sie ja zu dieser Saison hin, also in der letzten Saison war es so, dass sie durch eine Konstellation am letzten Spieltag, eine Niederlage von Köln sind, sie noch auf den ersten Platz in der Arme.
Nein, durch einen Sieg von uns in Bochum.
Genau. Und sie haben natürlich, das ist natürlich ihr Dreh, aber dazu gehörte noch eine Niederlage vom ersten Spieltag.
Aber ich sehe als Trainer immer alle Spiele zusammen. Wer hat wie viele gewonnen? Wer hat unentschieden gespielt? Wie viel? Und wer hat wie auch verloren?
Okay, da möchte ich mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt auch gar nicht mit hinkriegen. Sie sind dann ins Halbfinale der A-Bundesliga gekommen, da dann gegen einen gewissen Verein aus der Nachbarschaft dann verloren. Und jetzt zur neuen Saison hin hat sich ein bisschen das umgesetzt, was Sie jetzt auch schon vorhin gesagt haben, wo Schalke ein bisschen nachlegen muss, nämlich auch Quereinsteiger zu ermöglichen. Also sie haben jetzt eine ganze Reihe von Spielern mit dazu bekommen. Waren Sie dann zum Beispiel auch bei jedem der verpflichtenden Gespräche mit dabei, um die da kennenzulernen?
Ja, selbstverständlich.
Und wie verändert das Ihre Arbeit, wenn das nicht Spieler sind, wo Ihnen dann schon der U17-Trainer sagt, also ich habe den jetzt zwei Jahre bei mir gehabt, der tickt so und so, in den und den Bereichen müssten wir wahrscheinlich noch was tun. Wie verändert das Ihre Arbeit jetzt, mit so vielen Quereinsteigern in eine neue Saison zu gehen?
Es wird sehr spannend, weil in der Form hatten wir es noch nicht. Muss ich aber noch ein bisschen weiter ausführen? Das letzte Jahr, die Westdeutsche Meisterschaft, war überhaupt nicht zu erwarten. Es war mindestens so ein großer Erfolg wie die deutschen Meisterschaften 2016, 2012, 2015. Weil wir hatten im letzten Jahr – und damit trete ich meinen Jungs überhaupt nicht so nahe, weil die haben was Großartiges geleistet – hatten aber zwei sehr durchschnittliche Jahrgänge. Da war der BVB Köln und auch noch die eine oder andere Anwandschaften mehr. Also spielerisch individuell uns überlegen. Also das war eine großartige Leistung. Letztendlich haben wir mit dem ersten Platz in der Liga uns in der Liga vor dem deutschen Meister positioniert. Positiv gesehen. Also war das Halbfinale für uns eigentlich schon, poah, haben wir ja nie mit gerechnet und haben das auch gut gemacht. Letztendlich war Dortmund einen Tacken stärker, aber wir haben da schon recht gut mitgehalten. Und die sind ja hinterher auch verdienter deutscher Meister geworden in Stuttgart. Aber neue Saison, wir haben zwei Dinge getan. Wir haben diesmal so viele Quereinsteiger geholt, nicht nur, weil wir wieder mehr Unterstützung haben, sondern weil es einfach nötig war und ist. Denn die beiden Jahrgänge, der Jungjahrgang vom letzten Jahr, die werden ja jetzt in der neuen Saison Altjahrgänge. Und der Jahrgang, der jetzt hochkommt, also die neuen Jungjahrgänge, letztes Jahr B-Jung, sind auch eher durchschnittlich, sind schon gute Jungs dabei. Also auch da will ich keinen zu nahe treten. Wir halten viel von ihnen, aber deutlich schwächer als in den letzten 10, 12 Jahren. Und von daher waren wir jetzt einfach in der Pflicht, auszugleichen. Und auf der anderen Seite, das mussten wir tun, um auch weiterhin auf verschiedenen Ebenen mithalten zu können. Und auf der anderen Seite natürlich auch, um den einen oder anderen mehr zu haben, den wir über den Quereinstieg – es sind ja dann immer noch ein, zwei Jahre – da denke ich immer wieder Özil, Kolasinac und McKennie. Und es gibt mehr, die später dazugehört worden sind, dass wir dann auch da weiter erfolgreich dual fahren können. Nämlich Spieler, die schon lange bei uns sind und hochkommen und Spieler, die dazugekommen sind. Machen andere Vereine auch. Ist jetzt aber nicht aus einer neuen Philosophie geboren, sondern einfach den Umständen, aus den Umständen entstanden, weil wir das tun mussten.
Und wie hat sich da der Markt verändert? Das Thema hatten wir vorhin schon mal so kurz angeschnitten. Was jetzt eben darum geht, so Spieler, die eben erst 15, 16 Jahre alt sind, zu einem Verein zu holen. Merken sie da auch, dass sich was verändert hat?
Spieler werden definitiv immer eher an ihre Clubs gebunden. Das ist auch, da bin ich nicht so genau drin in den Regularien, aber das ist den Auflagen auch geschuldet. Das hat mit Ausbildungsentschädigungen zu tun, die inzwischen verstärkt gezahlt werden müssen. Das macht auch Sinn. Aber die Spieler sind deutlich eher gebunden, sodass es schon immer schwerer wird, auch Quereinsteiger zu holen. Das ist uns diesmal, das wird ja dann in den nächsten Jahren in der Form auch sicherlich nicht mehr so der Fall sein. Alle Vereine holen 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 Spieler, bei uns sind es jetzt mal ein paar mehr. Das wird in den nächsten Jahren dadurch, dass wir jetzt beide Jahrgänge ausgeglichen haben und die Jahrgänge, die jetzt kommen, wieder stärker sind, wird bei uns sicherlich dieses Jahr in der Beziehung auch eine Ausnahme sein.
Verfolgen Sie solche journalistische Berichterstattung, wie Sie zum Beispiel die Football-Leaks zutage gefördert haben, dass man gesehen hat, bei Spielern, die minderjährig sind, darf ja noch kein Geld anteilig am Berater fließen. Und dann konnte aber nachgewiesen werden, dass es da Abmachungen gibt oder Konstellationen, indem man das dann zum Beispiel über einen Job, den man dann einem der Elternteile vermittelt, auffängt. Oder zum Beispiel, dass man sagt, am 18. Geburtstag gibt es auf einmal eine Überweisung. Oder dass es auch ganz andere Modelle gibt, wie zum Beispiel Manchester City, die sich eine Jugendschule, eine Fußballschule in Afrika quasi so zu eigen gemacht haben, dass jeder, der aus dieser Schule rausgeht, dass Manchester City mehr oder minder über dessen fußballerisches Schicksal verfügen kann. Verfolgen sie solche Berichterstattung und glauben sie, dass man da von Seiten der Verbände mehr reglementieren müsste? Es geht ja hier um junge Menschen.
Ja, es kommt immer darauf an, welche Interessen. Das Interesse des einzelnen Menschen oder der Menschen sollte immer an erster Stelle stehen. Aber auch häufig stehen Machtinteressen darüber, Institutionen darüber, dass das das verfolge ich schon. Sprechen sie auch was bestimmtes an?
Naja, zum Beispiel eben diese Fußballschule von Manchester City. Es gab jetzt im Zuge von Kai Havertz, da wurde eben zum Beispiel so eine Überweisung fällig, ohne dass ich jetzt die Originaldokumente natürlich gesehen hätte. Ich gebe da jetzt nur die Berichterstattung des Spiegels wieder. Aber wir hatten eben solche Fälle auch innerhalb Deutschlands, auch zum Eintracht Frankfurt wurde da auch fast schon in Anführungszeichen Opfer eines solchen Falles, weil ihnen auch ein Spieler vermittelt wurde, bei dem im Hintergrund dann Geld floss, was aber der Verein erst im Nachhinein raus war.
Wo fließt denn kein Geld? Sagen Sie mir mal, ein Verein in Deutschland, wo kein Geld fließt, der dann den Leistungszentrum hat oder der Bundesliga ist.
Naja, wenn Sie jetzt einen 16-jährigen Spieler von wo auch immer zu Schalke holen, dann sollte ja da erstmal kein Geld fließen. So sind doch die Akte in Regularien.
Jetzt bin ich nicht derjenige, der für solche Dinge bei uns zuständig ist, aber ich kann mir das fast gar nicht vorstellen, dass das Geld irgendwo keine Rolle spielt. Ich bin aber bei Ihnen, es ist teilweise uferlos geworden, wie im großen Fußball auch. Also es gibt sicherlich Vereine, da gibt es schon für U19-Spieler, vor allem in England auch, da gibt es sicherlich, da gibt es schon Monatsgelder von 40.000, 50.000 Euro. Ich weiß jetzt nicht bei den ganz jungen, was da passiert, bin ich nicht exakt im Bild, sonst würde ich mich da auch klarer formulieren. Es gibt sicherlich auch Vereine, die in Deutschland schon überdimensional Gehälter zahlen im älteren Jugendbereich, sag ich jetzt mal so. Kann ich irgendwo verstehen, auf der anderen Seite nicht, gehe ich auch nicht so mit, wenn ich mal gefragt werde, was ein Spieler hier bei uns betrifft, weil ich einfach glaube, der Markt ist da, ein dummer Ausdruck für, wenn Menschen beteiligt sind, das Geschäft ist da, der Markt ist da. Es wird unglaublich viel umgesetzt im Fußball, halte ich aber nicht für sinnvoll, gerade im Jugendbereich nicht, weil ich glaube, dass die werden sowieso schon genug hochgejubelt. Und wenn du das Talent in den Vordergrund stellst und nicht mehr das Anstrengen und den Einsatz und dafür alles tun und wirst dann auch noch so hochbezahlt, so exorbitant hochbezahlt, kann das leicht Motivation töten. Aber ich bin zwar ein Fußballer-Romantiker, aber auch nicht blauäugig. Also ich weiß schon, dass Fußball im Jugendbereich definitiv auch eine sehr große Rolle spielt.
Also Sie meinen Geld im Jugendbereich?
Ja klar. Alles andere ist ja weltfremd und das weiß auch jeder und die bewegen sich dann, aber man bewegt sich natürlich dann im Bereich der Legalität. Da gibt es Auflagen dafür und da muss ja auch alles nachgewiesen werden. Also da machen Vereine jetzt nichts Illegales. Zumindest nicht soweit ich weiß.
Okay, ich könnte noch ganz lange mit Ihnen sprechen, aber so langsam muss ich Sie dann doch mal auch wieder an Ihre Saisonvorbereitung lassen. Sie sprechen in Ihrem Buch am Schluss noch die generelle Wertschätzung von Nachwuchstrainer im deutschen Fußball an und auch das Zertifizierungssystem, das der DFB und die DFL zusammen etabliert haben, um eben den deutschen Nachwuchs zu fördern. Wo, glauben Sie, steht Deutschland in seiner Entwicklung? Was fehlt noch, um den Bereich des Juniorenfußballs, des Nachwuchsfußballs, hin zum Leistungs- und Profifußball zu verbessern?
Ich glaube nach wie vor, dass wir immer noch zur unteren Weltspitze gehören. Mit der Zertifizierung meinte ich, grundsätzlich fand ich die gut. Wobei sich jeder Trainer, jeder Mitarbeiter und permanent sowieso hinterfragen sollte, wie wir besser werden. Die Frage muss man sich persönlich und als Gruppe jeden Tag stellen. Der Grundgedanke der Zertifizierung war, sicherlich auch Unterstützung und Ansätze zu geben. Es waren viele Dinge dabei, die hilfreich waren. Aber in einem Bereich hat es dazu geführt, zu sehr zu einer Vereinheitlichung. Jeder Mensch ist anders, jedes Unternehmen ist anders, jeder Verein ist anders. Das hat, um es schnell und einfach zu formulieren, etwas zu einer Vereinheitlichung geführt.
Weil man gewisse Punkte erfüllen musste, um das Zertifizieren zu bekommen.
Alle wollten diese drei Sterne, drei Sterne, drei Plus, haben. Alle haben sich sehr an diesen Katalog gehalten, um die drei Sterne zu bekommen. Dabei kannst du dich und dein eigenes Leben, deine eigene Philosophie, deine eigene Idee so ein bisschen verlieren. Das hat dann sicherlich auch dazu geführt, dass zu sehr alle nach dem Gleichen gestrebt haben, mit allem das Gleiche wollen. Da geht auch ein bisschen Kreativität, geht auch wieder ein bisschen, ja eine eigene Philosophie haben, geht ein bisschen verloren. Könnten Sie die Frage nochmal wiederholen, weil das ist die Schwerste, wo wir noch…
Genau, also wenn Sie zum Beispiel sagen, dass Deutschland noch in der unteren Weltspitze stehen, was das angeht, dann wäre jetzt die erste Anschlussfrage erstmal, wer ist denn da für Sie top? An wem könnte man sich denn orientieren?
Ja, sehr spannend. Gerade in Europa sind Spanien und Portugal, natürlich auch England und Frankreich. Warum, weshalb, ob das Migrationsgründe hat oder nicht, bin ich nicht so tief da drin. Da spielen natürlich viele Dinge auch eine Rolle. Es hat sehr viel mit Jahrgängen zu tun auch. Das wird man auch noch sehen. Jetzt der U21-Jahrgang, der gilt als sehr stark. Die kommenden Jahrgänge sind nicht ganz so stark. Und wenn Jahrgänge nicht ganz so stark sind, deswegen kann man dann auch nicht verallgemeinern und sagen, ja, da sind wir, da trainieren wir nicht gut genug. Die Ansätze müssen wir natürlich haben und verfolgen, uns immer weiter verbessern zu wollen oder auch zu sagen, das haben wir nicht so gut gemacht. Aber es hat schon mit Jahrgängen zu tun. Ich glaube, das Wichtigste wird sein, dass wir wieder die Spielintelligenz und die Technik in den Vordergrund stellen, aber auch Anstrengungsbereitschaft, Einstellung, dass wir diese Dinge mindestens auf einer Höhe mit Talent vielleicht sogar darüber stellen. Weil vieles ist auch hier bei uns zu leicht geworden. Und wenn du dich nicht mehr anstrengst, um irgendwas zu erreichen, dann wirst du. Und wenn du nur gelobt wirst für Intelligenz und Talent und für deine Fähigkeiten statt für Anstrengungsbereitschaft, für Wille, für Arbeitsmoral, für üben, üben, üben, üben, dann bleibt vieles auf der Strecke. Das ist für mich ein ganz wichtiger Faktor. Gerade hier bei uns in Deutschland, weil in Deutschland geht es uns, Gott sei Dank, immer noch im Schnitt verdammt gut. Vielleicht ist ein bisschen der Hunger auf der Strecke geblieben, beziehungsweise die Förderung des Hungers.
Wenn ich dann allerdings gucke, wo es noch Hunger gibt, dann sehe ich eine zweite Entwicklung, die aber dann irgendwie damit auch zusammenhängt, nämlich dass wir neue Trainerbiografien auch haben, also dass wir angefangen vielleicht mit Thomas Tuchel als jemand, der quasi dem Fußball fremd war, in dem Sinne, dass er keine Profifußballkarriere hatte, aus dem Jugendbereich es schafft, in der Bundesliga zu landen. Und davon haben wir jetzt ja eine ganze Reihe von erfolgreichen Trainerkarrieren. Und es scheint so zu sein, als wäre das auch dann Antrieb für viele andere Jugendtrainer. Ist es jetzt, dass wir eben zum Beispiel einen Julian Nagesmann, einen Thomas Tuchel, einen Florian Kohfeldt und wie sie alle heißen, dass wir die alle bis in die erste Bundesliga mitverfolgen durften, ist das jetzt Ausdruck dafür, dass es gerade eine goldene Trainergeneration gibt? Oder ist es vielleicht nicht auch ein Symptom dafür, dass dem Nachwuchsbereich das Renommee fehlt, dass solche Trainer, ohne jetzt die persönlich zu meinen, aber quasi diese Art von Trainer sagt, mir genügt es im Nachwuchsbereich, nachhaltig so wie sie vielleicht mal für 20 Jahre Arbeit zu machen?
Ja, jeder weiß und kennt die Wichtigkeit. Das wird häufig auch ausgesprochen. Aber Wertschätzung äußert sich über verschiedene Ebenen. Das Wertschätzung kann man formulieren, kann man ausdrücken. Aber es lässt sich auch über eine entsprechende Bezahlung und eine interne Wertschätzung darstellen. Und da ist der Nachwuchstraining – ich spreche nicht von mir, das hat aber auch 20 Jahre gedauert, bis ich mich mal aus dem Radar schiebe. Aber das war ja gewollt. Also das ist ja keine Klage.
Aber auch bei Ihnen wollte Rudi Assauer damals das Gehalt wieder reduzieren, als Sie nach Ihrer Co-Trainer-Tätigkeit wieder als U19-Trainer angefangen haben. Da haben Sie sich dann gegenverwehrt. Aber das zeigt ja quasi die Denke, dass eben dieser Job weniger wert ist, tatsächlich finanziell gesprochen.
Ja, das ist so. Ich kenne ja auch so ein bisschen die läufigen Zahlen. Das ist definitiv so. Auf der anderen Seite ist ein Grund natürlich der finanzielle Aspekt, dass viele heute ganz schnell nach oben wollen, weil die Fleisch-Stöpfe, die sind nur oben, und es wird eben dem Profibereich exorbitant bezahlt. Und das ist ja auch verständlich. Geld ist flüssige Energie, betone ich ja immer wieder. Sollte nicht an erster Stelle stehen im Leben, ist aber wichtig. Deswegen kann ich das auch nachvollziehen. Viele streben dann eben sehr schnell auch in die Öffentlichkeit, weil du dann eben die entsprechende Aufmerksamkeit medial, die entsprechende Wertschätzung eben bekommst. Deswegen kann ich das nachvollziehen, dass viele Trainer das machen. Das muss aber jeder für sich selber entscheiden. Aber die Wertschätzung ist nach wie vor nicht stark genug ausgeprägt. Da kann man darüber reden, häufig wird es formuliert, aber man kann es auch zeigen durch sein Verhalten, indem die Vereinsbosse sich entsprechend verhalten. Oder kann man sich was einfallen lassen, das ist nicht immer nur die finanzielle Schiene. Es sind viele Trainer-Talente dabei, große Talente, auf die sie jetzt genannt haben, plus auch der eine oder andere mehr. Das ist richtig so. Die sind auch richtig gut. Das, was ihnen fehlt, ist Erfahrung. Und Erfahrung kriegst du nur durch Erfahrung. Und deswegen muss jeder Verein sich das sehr, sehr genau überlegen. Ich hole einen dieser hochtalentierten, jungen Trainer, dann weiß ich, was der hat, weiß aber auch genau, was er nicht hat. Und für schwierige Situationen, wenn es richtig, richtig schwer wird, brauchst du Erfahrung.
Aber Sie würden ausschließen, dass wir Sie noch mal als Cheftrainer in der Bundesliga sehen. Sie hatten ja zweimal die Möglichkeit nach Slomka und nach Di Matteo und beide Male haben Sie gesagt, nein, danke.
Ausschließen würde ich das nicht. Es ist aber nicht in meinem Lebensplan. Aber ausschließen definitiv nicht. Ich betone ja immer wieder, dass ich das, was ich mache, sonst könnte ich das auch nicht so lange. Das können Sie nicht so lange. Ein Job, der so viel, jetzt mache ich das bis zur Rente und bin froh, wenn das endlich vorbei ist, da verstehe ich viele Menschen. Es kommt ja auch darauf an, in welcher Zeit ist man groß geworden und wie waren die Lebensumstände und und und. Aber im Moment würde ich es eher noch so sehen, dass ich für mich den größeren Sinn in meiner jetzigen Aufgabe sehe. Da bin ich dann ganz bei Viktor Frenkel, einem der größten Psychologen aller Zeiten. Ich glaube, es war der Begründer der Logotherapie, der gesagt hat, der Mensch wird nur etwas durch die Aufgabe, die er zu der Seinen macht. Heißt aber nicht, dass ich irgendwann nicht mal sage, also ausschließend tue ich es nicht.
Sehr gut. Jetzt habe ich meinen Aufmacherzitat. Nein, Quatsch, so funktioniert der Rasenfunk nicht. Herr Elgert, ich danke Ihnen sehr, gebe alles nun hier auf. Die Erfolgsstrategien vom Trainer der Weltstars ist das Buch, was Sie geschrieben haben, zusammen mit dem Journalisten Kai Psotter. Es ist erschienen im Ariston Verlag und hat uns unter anderem dieses schöne Gespräch beschert. Vielen Dank, Herr Elgert.
Ja, ich bedanke mich bei Ihnen für das spannende Gespräch. Viele schwierige Fragen.
Das ist ein bisschen mein Markenzeichen.
Aber das sollte auch so sein. Ich kann Ihnen eins sagen, das hat mich richtig gefordert. Danke auch dafür.
Okay, das freut mich. Danke, dass wir hier in Ihre Kabine rein durften. Bis auf bald, hoffentlich.
Ja, alles Gute und nochmals herzlichen Dank Ihnen, nur für Ihre Zukunft. Das ist von Herzen das Allerbeste.
So endet unser Gespräch mit Norbert Elgert. Wir hoffen, ihr hattet euren Spaß an dieser Unterhaltung. Lasst uns gerne Feedback da unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de oder über alle sozialen Kanäle, die euch so zur Verfügung stehen. Ihr könnt natürlich auch an der Verlosung teilnehmen. Solltet ihr Supporterinnen oder Supporter sein oder vielleicht in unsere anderen Formate reinhören. Es gibt noch die Rasenfunk Schlusskonferenz, da sprechen wir über den vergangenen Bundesligaspieltag bzw. wir haben jetzt auch Sendungen zur Frauen-WM und zur U21-EM produziert. Es gibt noch weitere Tribünengespräche, zum Beispiel mit Richard Goltz über 21 Jahre Bundesliga-Fußball, mit Thomas Bräuch über dessen Karriere, aber auch zeitlose Themen wie zum Beispiel der FIFA-Prozess, von dem man wieder erstaunlich wenig hört aktuell. Dabei laufen da immer noch ein paar Verhandlungen in New York. Auch das könnt ihr euch vielleicht reinziehen. Und es gibt noch den Rasenfunk Kurzpass für kürzere Sendungen. Vielleicht ist da ja auch was für euch mit dabei. Wir freuen uns in jedem Fall, wenn ihr dem Rasenfunk treu bleibt, wenn ihr vielleicht diese Folge auch weiterempfehlt und uns bewertet bei iTunes und den ganzen Plattformen, die es gibt. Vielen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bis hoffentlich bald mal wieder im Rasenfunk. Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.